Mm,
I want to tell you one story,
and the story came from the early 19
fifties,
a woman named Wanda,
Ruth Lunsford,
who was the scientist in New York City
and she published one paper which turned
out to be our one paper in science,
so we just actually push data science.
What she did was she took an old rat in
a young rat.
She put him to sleep and she tied their
skin together.
So after about a day or so,
their blood supplies joined.
Well,
several weeks later she looked in that
old rat.
There were new neurons growing in the
brain,
the heartbeat stronger,
and the muscles were bigger.
The gray hair term brown again,
she claimed she reversed aging.
People call her dracula or Frankenstein,
all kinds of crazy names.
Well,
earlier this year,
three separate laboratories at Harvard,
Stanford University of California,
San Francisco repeated the experiment
and it worked,
and what they showed is at age 25,
and you and I are stem cells go to sleep
and get turned off and proteins from
young mice in this case or young humans
can turn them back on again.
And when these stem cells get turned
back on,
new neurons can be growed,
repair happens much quicker and tissue
and tissue we all see read,
our child breaks his leg.
He or she are back walking again a
couple of weeks.
I don't even know what happened.
Your grandmother breaks her leg and it
hits her quality life the rest of her
life.
So there are clinical trials now using
proteins that were founding young
individuals to try to stimulate bone
repair in the elderly who have
fractures.
And so just like a diabetic requires a
shot of insulin so that they can manage
their sugar going forward.
If you break your leg in the elderly,
we may just give you a shot of these
proteins to turn back on your stem cells
so you can repair quicker.
We're trying it in cancer because cancer
in kids is about 90 percent curable.
Once you turn 25,
that same cancer turns incurable.
So maybe if I can give it to the body,
it's younger.
I can have a.
We as a science community can have a
bigger impact on cancer.
So I leave you with that bit of hope,
that aging is something that may be able
to be reversed and not so we can live
till I'm 150,
but so that we can all live until our
ninth or 10th decade without there being
a decrease in quality in those last
decades.
Because that'd be the goal quality years
till the end.